寒いなんかねあの個人的な意見なんですけども長袖長ズボンが大嫌いなんですよもう体
に触れる感じがちょっと苦手だからできる限り生きてライナー半袖半ズボンでいたいっ
ていう僕の小さな願いですまあなかなか寒い傷になりましたね
今回はこちらゼンガー初代前かでございます前回の動画で使ったんですけども姉だけの
ためにある後と思った
ないと思ったねこれからエコーの選手で何でもやっていいけどさぁ
ジェンガを組み立てるだけで終わるともったいないと思ったので今回はこの巨大前が
追加でさらに買いました
こちらいやぁなかなかの量になりましたねかなりの量のジェンカがありますそこでさあ
に私は気付いなこの前がの上に人が乗れるかどうかこれ実は人がジェンガの上に
うーんちょっと待ってよ
ちょたんんまぁも2つだと人が取れるんですよねこれ待ってほらほらん
ほら振るだちょっと取れないかと思ったけど2つあった人はなりません
ほら大丈夫大丈夫みますよねで今回はこの大量のジェンガを使って会案を作っていると
思います
それ夢だったんだよジェンダーで階段を作ったねほんと見て結構も丈夫なんで全然
いけると思うんですけども俺自身までもっと上のランクにクティも込めて
をもっと上に行きたいわけですよ人としてねから今回はここでねちょっと前なで階段を
作って歌にか
てあげたいと思います何よいう実は行こうよっこ観光作って最後と駒田はに今
ライミング出来るみたいな3 za かつやっていこうと思います
バッハ
うんうん
なぜどう書あ
者狩り内観はぁっはぁっはぁっ
阿部もアウト宣伝みたいな待った版足りないかな
自分ちょっと足りないみたいなちょっと講師でございます
だこれでになりますねもう一ないけどショップ勘助金爆の中に於てもこれぐらいじゃ
ないとできないんですよ
怖いわ結構チャンス連山からもうちょっと浮いてるんじゃないか
攻めすぎるとかえって俺が死ぬからマージンたくはないんですよ
持った
の
ん
カフェ
はいという意味で分前後で腕ができたんですけども表利数が少なかったんでちょっと
ハイム的なビューになっちゃったんですけどもう全然書いたんですがもう見てもらって
分かると思うんですけどもうこのだんだんだんだんだ
バンッ飛びますかあと前が弱かったり僕がついてくださいすると北比良するとしてい
ます
割とビビってますよ神ですからねかみかみで作った階段みたいなと思いますから
工具なんてちょっとええんじゃないよやるしかねーな
気合いますどうやっていこうかなースピード値幅がかかっていた方がいいのか1本ずつ
確実に首絞め
豚舎もいいね by 食べるぞ水
21さぞ
国でプレーちょっとわから強いずはを実現して冷静に冷静に
カムダンカン観光客パンパンパンパンパン5
いましぇい21
ます
見てもらった通りスピードへ行くと安定が長くなるんでやっぱ会談は安全しっかり
踏みしめていこうと思いますよ
次こそ成功しますかね
でガーッ
水
q 12ぞ
しっかりと見て趣味で見知らぬ人次はこれ使うねー
ほらほら車えっ
またたら泣いちゃったまた飛び越えていこう
曲いいよ
いけるいけるよ
頬はぁっ